agriculture in the United States is the
more than 360 billion dollar annual
business but it's in trouble American
farmers are getting older their average
age is just over 58 and farming in
general faces a major labor shortage
Errol Barnett met with some growers to
see how they are trying to find a
solution with the help of technology
from Silicon Valley he's he's at hard
rock hard rock Hill orchard in Mount
Airy Maryland Errol good morning good
morning look we know that farming is
tough work you've got to get up before
dawn and to take care of cows like these
you have to bring them through this
milking machine twice a day now
generally speaking though this is just
not the type of work people want to do
anymore it is becoming more difficult to
find all sorts of agricultural labor now
farmers I met with recently told me that
the key to fix that is artificial
intelligence look at that bad boy
yeah there try this should be sweet for
just about a hundred years Wow Gary rush
not Sookie's family has been running the
wish fruit farm business I think my
grandfather he was alive wouldn't be
just totally mesmerized by what the
future is turned into in order to keep
his crop healthy he needs six hundred
people to harvest 600 acres every two to
three days but finding that amount of
labor is becoming unsustainable we've
seen a shrinking labor force and an
aging labor force
we actually had fields we were
abandoning early in the season which is
a really painful thing for a grower to
do in an effort to avoid losing $20,000
per acre on abandoned fields gary
partnered with the team of engineers who
are working to fully automate the
process we've separated all of the
things that a picker is doing and the
various pieces of the robot Pohl Bisset
is the chief operating officer of the
company behind it all we're collecting
50 to 100 images a plan and all of those
images are fed in
I system in order to tell us okay this
is a good berry this is one we want to
go out so you're telling me in real time
this machine is looking at the plan
thinking what to do next
based on the imaging and then executing
that action exactly so is this as fast
as a human right now this machine
commercialized will replace the 30
people that you saw in the field earlier
today with Gary strawberry farmers are
so excited about this harvester
two-thirds of the industry invested more
than five million dollars into its
development all in hopes to replace the
cost of human labor some would complain
that machines and artificial
intelligence are actually displacing
people who want to have these jobs
you're saying this actually fixes a
problem you have the workforce is not
here we've currently had to turn to
guest worker visas to bring people in on
a short-term basis to get the crop
harvested this is a global problem the
lack of farm labor John Deere combine
advises farming Maine State John Deere
is turned to autonomy and is expanding
into Silicon Valley it spent more than
300 million dollars on a tech startup
using drone imaging to reduce use of
pesticides the IDA helps me to check
with my cows and one Dutch company is
using tensorflow google's AI platform to
track dairy cow behavior it's being
tested in Augusta Georgia by Richard
Watson it can determine just by her
movements whether she is drinking
whether she's eating whether she's lying
down standing up walking he hopes the
app can give him a heads up of his 2,000
dairy cows are sick even before they
show symptoms and alerted me to the fact
that there was one animal that is in
heat which is she is ready to be bred
and there are three animals that may
have a potential health problem Watson
says the number of u.s. dairy farmers
dropped by 50% in the past 20 years yet
the number of dairy cows is the same
when it was 80 to 100 cows the dairy
farmer just about knew their animals by
name I could tell you just about
everything about them we just can't do
that now what the technology enables you
to do has become
a more efficient and perhaps diagnose
things quicker and and treat things
quicker google spokesman Justin Bieber
says the game-changer here is the
interpretation of the data and it's
figuring these things out day by day
week by week the more amount of training
data that it gets the smarter it count
becomes it learns the cows it learns the
farmers and it's able to give more
effective information no technology is a
silver bullet the key question for food
sustainability expert Daniele Nierenberg
is how this new food tech will change
things it can't all be about profit it
has to be able out the long term
viability of a food system and food
security for everyone back in Florida
where commercialization of these AI bugs
is still years away
they say the consumer is the focus how
excited are you about what you're doing
here yeah I'm really excited
somebody recent asked me what I wanted
my legacy to be and I answered I said I
think I want to be that I saved the US
strawberry industry now gary says
without automation you can expect to pay
$100 for a bunch of strawberries during
the off-peak winter season and I have to
show you this new baby calf born last
night milk prices are relatively low
right now but Richard tells me any
efficiency you add to the mix helps to
keep those costs low Gail Wow a new baby
calf that's so precious thank you very
much so we got a new Prince and we have
a new baby calf although I wonder skill
I know that that's a stand if I have not
seen before I always wonder about how
those baby calves and elephants how they
arrived in the world I get it for
everybody else but four legs coming out
- seems really complicated to me and
every time I see when I got that word
thank you very much enjoy your Cheerios
calve is here and all is right with
whistle we'll get out the whiteboard